Elephants are so different
from us anatomically
that you would think there
would be very few parallels,
and yet the more we learn
about elephant society
the more parallels we see.
They seem to have
very strong social bonds.
Females stay in their family
groups their whole lives.
And the males will stay
in their family group
until they become teenagers,
and then they will move out and
they will hang out with other males
in what's known
as a bachelor herd.
The calves get raised by their
relatives as well as their mum.
So sisters, brothers, aunties,
cousins, grandma
all contribute to the raising of
the calf, much like we used to.
Elephants are really amazing
at staying in touch.
Elephants will communicate with
each other using vocalisations,
making sounds that are
within human hearing range,
but we know that they also use
something called infrasound
which is a very low-frequency sound.
And the thing about infrasound
is that it travels over very long
distances, it can travel many miles.
And so we believe that elephants,
when they separate from
each other in groups,
that they will keep in touch with
each other using infrasound
and they will use that to coordinate
their movements with each other,
eventually meeting back
up together again.
For us in the Western world, and
in big cities with so many people,
loneliness is a problem,
is a massive social illness.
The behaviour of elephants suggests
that they are aware of death
and that they do grieve
and show emotion
when members of their family die.
And they also show interest
in the remains of elephants
that they might not have known.
And I quote someone
called Kyle Owens,
who was working
in Burkina Faso in 1986.
He witnessed a remarkable scene
while watching a herd of eight
elephants with a tiny baby.
He saw that the baby was ill,
and throughout the morning,
the mother tried everything
to raise the calf to its feet.
He says at dusk he returned,
the baby had died.
Its tiny body was barely visible
as the other elephants had covered
him with dirt and grass and leaves.
The mother positioned herself
over her child and began to rock.
Occasionally other elephants
would stroke her back affectionately
or intertwine trunks.
She continued to rock
as darkness fell.
Like elephants we grieve,
it's normal and it's very common
and it's something that we're all
going to experience in life.
Even though you have to go on
without this person in your life,
you can live through the memories
that you've had over the years.
Elephants touch each other
with their trunks,
and this physical contact
seems to provide comfort.
So an elephant that
has appeared distressed,
when another elephant
comes over to it
and seems to be comforting it using
its trunk, and touching it,
the other elephant
seems to then relax,
and seems to show less distress.
So, similar to hugging.
Comfort, affection, touching,
hugging, kissing,
is quite a reassurance that,
OK, there's some support there.
You want people to feel supported,
you want them feel like they
are part of this society,
they are part of this world,
and they have got a purpose here.